My name is Jordy.
I live in the Netherlands, in Rotterdam,
and I'm doing some work
in theatres and dance performances.
To use your whole body
is an important thing to me in dance.
And also your mind
and the things I have in mind
I can open them up
and throw them on the ground
and play with it!
The name of the play was "Piazza della Vita".
These play performances are about a square
where people are going,
walking, eating, drinking, sitting...
And we are...
The actors are playing a role in it
to be the people who are relating
on the streets, eating
or regular people that you meet.
The whole story is also about
life and death,
and being born again.
I want to be more in inclusive dance,
participating,
I want to make a lot of performances,
but one performance I'm thinking of
is with a group of ten people
and I want to create in chaos performances.
Not about another language
or something that you see
but about some particles
of your experience
and with all the ten people you are going
into the frying pan, and make something.
Those are my ambitions.